from World War two hero to Texas
congressman UN ambassador
CIA director vice president and then
President George HW Bush has left a
lasting legacy on this country but when
asked about that six years ago he said
he would he banned the l word adding I
think history will point out the things
I did wrong and perhaps some of the
things I did right here to discuss all
those things from our Washington bureau
is CBS's Bob Schieffer Bob good morning
good morning it really was a heck of a
life wasn't it well it was you know he I
covered him in the 1980 campaign when he
ran unsuccessfully for president and
then his 88 campaign when he was elected
and I will never forget the the first
time I ever interviewed him he actually
in 1981 the Iowa caucuses and beat
Reagan and so forth and and he was on
CBS the next morning and I said so how
do you feel he said I feel like I've got
Big Mo and I said what he said big mo
big Moe and I said I've never heard this
term and I said I'm sorry I don't know
what you mean he said mo mo mo momentum
side of him there Bob without a doubt
has anyone ever been more qualified to
be President than President Bush was you
know that's a very good that's a very
good question because he was very well
qualified he had been an elected
politician he'd been chairman of the
Republican National Committee later on
he was the head of the CIA he was our
first envoy to China after we recognized
China
he really was especially in foreign
policy prepared but the interesting
thing about him even though he was a war
hero you know he was the youngest pilot
shot down in a fighter plane in World
War two he he truly he was an
entrepreneur he had this great you know
ability to go to Texas and start up his
own company and yet he was so nice he
was so proper that some people
took that for weakness and Newsweek in
the 88 campaign actually ran a cover
with his picture on the front that said
the wimp factor he was anything but a
wimp and yet his people said we've got
to change this image that year he'd lost
in Iowa they redid the campaign they
went to New Hampshire and the way they
decided to make him be more manly as it
were is he abandoned the coat and tie
started wearing trucker tractor hats and
windbreakers and things like that and
drove every piece of heavy machinery
fine in New Hampshire I mean at one
point somebody said to me hide the
forklift mama George Bush years ago he
would he would he would drive tractors
he would drive snowplows and once he
drove this 18-wheeler truck he only
drove it around a parking lot and the
Secret Service was hanging off the side
but he was driving around out there
Tooting the horn honk honk it would go
and the thing is American politics being
what it is he won he beat Bob Dole and
went on to get the nomination but he was
truly one of the kindest and people that
I ever knew he probably had more friends
than any president I ever knew and he
you know he never he didn't write his
own biography he was so shy about about
being in public life but he never lost
the opportunity to write people to
thank-you note and there must be a
million of them out there somewhere he
was really it was really a nice man and
Bob III think about those two Senate
races that he lost and the first bid for
president that he lost defeat never
defined George Bush did it no for just
just the way we're talking about but you
know I think you talked you all talked
in the beginning was he the most
qualified person to ever take the office
I mean who knows what qualifies someone
to be President but he had all of this
experience and in the end I
think what will remember him for is
number one the invasion of Iraq when
Saddam Hussein had invaded Kuwait he
drove him out American forces dead and
he got other countries in that region to
pay for it which was a was a remarkable
thing but I think even more important
than that in history he was the one who
was in office when the Soviet Union came
apart when it collapsed and I think the
way he guided American reaction to that
he would not allow you know a lot of
bragging and and talking about how you
know we're superior to them and all that
he just kind of played it cool and I
think the tone that he took other
countries our allies and friends took
the very same tone and I think it
probably got us to a very difficult time
that who knows what might have happened
if some desperate person in the Soviet
Union they had all these nuclear weapons
and decided to try to overturn this so I
think he gets great credit for that but
we got we just have a minute left here
but but at the end of the Gulf War at
which you mentioned of course President
Bush's approval rating was almost 90%
yet he ended up losing the next election
to Bill Clinton how hard was that defeat
for him well it was very difficult
because what it was he had to break the
campaign promise he had gone through
that campaign with the mantra no new
taxes read my lips no new taxes and then
the country got into an economic bind
and he had to do just like just that and
they were the American people somehow
they his his popularity went went down
sharply and he lost the election the
last great soldier soldier statesman and
certainly a different era of politics
and politician Bob Schieffer thank you
for sharing the memories thank you you
bet